elle ressemble à son père ananda devi
alain comme elle l'appelle se porte très
bien dit elle dans un éclat de rire
à côté d'elle l'oeil l'ami de toujours
le ballon de la première heure qui avec
alain peters a révolutionné la musique
réunionnaise en poussant les instruments
dans des retranchements très loin du
maloya et du séga très tendance de
l'époque alain peters sera le fil
conducteur d'une soirée hommage car il
est en vingt ans après le dernier
concert de carousel au théâtre en plein
air de saint-gilles
que son âme soit de nouveau
et de voir les choses arrivent et sont
concrètes
pour moi c'était le moment j'ai pas
portée allant jusque là je serais bien
incapable de le porter donc pour moi
c'était le moment j'avais envie de
d'être d'être présent d'être un peu à
l'initiative de lancer de relancer les
dalons
de l'époque de relancer aussi d'inviter
la relève laulhère liche qui s'efface
pour laisser place au génie du poète
disparu
la folie de petter si l'on n'a pas saisi
l'ampleur et il ne veut pas être
dépositaire de son héritage
alain peters n'a pas besoin de lui pour
continuer à exister
je suis heureux d'être là parce qu'alain
c'est une partie de ma vie c'est un ami
et puis c'est vrai qu'il ya 20 ans on se
retrouvait sur scène ensemble pour
l'hommage à carrousel et c'était une
période où alain était
en forme il a pu monter sur scène avec
nous et puis ça a laissé une trace
incroyable sa fédé et donc c'est juste
ya vingt ans donc voilà on va être sur
la même scène battant après donc c'est
vrai que c'est une émotion pour moi
sinon la musique à la nouvelle ville et
tout le temps elle était là quand il
était là et
avec moi
ils seront nombreux à reprendre les
titres du parabôle air à côté de l'oeil
on retrouve bernard brancard rené
lacaille mascotte pour les anciens
danyel waro christine salem nathalie
natiembe ceux d'hier mais également ceux
d'aujourd'hui qui ont forcément été
influencé par la mélodie de peters
dalons bernard joëlle gonthier
même mascotte aussi l'arrivée les
lacaille c'est sûr qu'on peut pas parler
à l'un sans associer justement toute
cette bande là avec et l'ouverture se
fera aussi par des artistes comme ça
hors d'âge
gilles au raid qui sera avec nous sur
notre formation à la guitare il ya aussi
des enfants comme ça ta fille katia mans
qui ce qui nous rejoint au théâtre il ya
les enfants de la caille donc laure
l'année puis son fils la musique d'alain
peters est plus que jamais vivante elle
a dépassé nos frontières on chante
allant brésil en hongrie ces sonorités
se retrouvent dans des reprises de jazz
et cet album par abu leur sortie en 1998
à une vie que je n'aurais même pas
imaginer à l'époque c'est à dire que
depuis 1998 il continue à être demandée
et à travers une distribution en france
c'est petit à petit vers d'autres pays
tels que le japon
d'autres pays européens amérique du nord
et puis après c'est une propagation part
d'internet
l'oeuvre de cet artiste a subitement été
reconnue et découvertes dans le monde
entier par des artistes de toutes
cultures musicales que ce soit des
musiciens de rock de jazz de musique
l'africaine brésilienne des rappeurs des
dj qui n'ont reprises ses oeuvres qui
les ont adaptés qui s'en sont inspirés
par bge à gallimard
genève les amants fin
est ce moi maria
pas même un nombre d'années vie propose
trois rendez vous à ceux qui veulent
replonger dans leurs souvenirs de
concerts simultanés ce vendredi au
palace à saint denis au kerveguen à
saint pierre tous les musiciens se
retrouveront ensuite ce samedi sur la
scène du théâtre de saint gilles pour
vivre un moment rare comme celui qu'ont
vécu ce qu'il y a 20 ans ont vu pour la
dernière fois à l'inspecteur chanter sur
cette même scène